salut il ya quelques semaines au mois de
décembre thomas de la chaîne top 10 est
venu sur ma chaîne et m'a fait un tour
tour de match qui m'a particulièrement
gonfler un peu énervé tu vois là je suis
énervé par exemple si vous n'avez pas vu
la vidéo je vous laisse la regarde et je
vous mets le lien dans la description je
vous quel est le bien à ce moment-là
précis il a fait un akan et nick hard
hat and number il s'est passé un truc
des normes
on a parlé de ce tour sur internet sur
les forums de magie en cherchant une
explication sans la trouver
j'ai aussi de mon côté chercher
d'explications partout vous avez vu rien
à voir mais on va bientôt être 400 mille
ici sur cette chaîne merci abonnez-vous
ya eu des messages dans les commentaires
disant que j'étais complice qui est
complètement faux avec une théorie du
complot comme quoi la vidéo fait 7 min
22 et j'ai choisi le set de kurt et en
22e position
bref j'ai appelé top 10 nous une ou 50
fois je lai un petit peu harceler parce
que j'ai ma théorie en fait sur le tour
et j'aimerais savoir si c'est ça jacques
j'ai quand même un doute je suis sûr de
moi 90% on va dire donc il m'a dit a pas
de problème fabien je passe chez toi je
te refais le tour et je te l'expliquer
énorme
[Musique]
vous l'avez reconnu c'est l'auteur de
tous ces méfaits c'est monsieur thomas
alias top-10 merci d'être là mec rien
merci de revenir alors j'ai une théorie
je l'exposé il ya un courant de la magie
dans le mentalisme aussi qu'il existe
qu'on appelle le jazz qui est le fait de
construire un tour avec parfois des baux
hazard qui peuvent arriver et 6e boisard
arrive tard est le tour ici ni vu ni
connu ni vu ni connu
donc d'après moi ma théorie est la
suivant ma théorie c'est qu'il y avait
une suite à ce tour et qu'au moment où
tu retournes et que tu vois le set de
coeur qui est en bonne position tu dis
merde c'est ça a marché c'est bon et ben
je m'arrête là
et bim j'ai bluffé olicard merci au
revoir quoi parce que ma théorie est
correct mais alors rien temps et bien
sûr si c'est pas la bonne carte est bien
pour moi tu as une suite si c'est pas la
bonne car tu t'arrêtes etc
tu dis au moins deux fois un genre comme
une fois je tire une carte jusqu'à ce
que ce soit non non non pour moi après
il ya une vraie suite peut-être en mode
et la regarde maintenant ça car je vais
faire ça pendant que tu fais ça toi tu
fais autre chose tu vois ce que lire bon
pied carrick et un petit truc
embrouilles à pipe hollande
moi si tu as ton propre paquet j'ai
attaqué les mêmes qui le font bien
tourner va pas bouger d'un iota
c'est un tout neuf elles sont elles sont
dans l'ordre non pour le pour le coup
veux tu que je mélange il faut les
mélanger parce qu'on m'a accusé dire que
je suis un mélange mais sachez qu'ils
avaient mélangé le jeu je l'avais
mélange aussi y'a pas de suède de chez
pasqua de même je suis le dernier mec
qui ferait en sorte qu'ils cachent
quelque chose sur cette scène je leur
permets regarder et l'a arrêté de dire
qu'il arrive à tout mémoriser maintenant
non c'est compliqué ces petits le retour
est petit et je vais même re mélanger
derrière et je coupe le jeu d'accord et
alors dans le tour je sais pas si tu te
dis venez je faisais un mélange oui à la
française tout à fait important que j'ai
mélangé outils le oui le paquet
abandonné dakar pas forcément que j'ai
revu les cartes mais une seule nom
maintenant c'est moi qui ai choisi la
carte anti mailhes donc on va faire ça
tu te souviens que j'avais recouper le
paquet oui
au coupé d'accord et là c'est la clau
tour eiffel et finalement on met à pagny
ma carte sim en numéro à ce moment là
oui mais toutes les cartes sont dans
l'ordre qu'il faut pour que quel que
soit le numéro et la carte qui tu veux
dire ça tombe bien
tu comprends quelle est ta carte
aujourd'hui les cinq de carreaux quel
est ton numéro le 11
donc on va compter ce qu'on va raconter
comme l'autre fois un jeu te conter
doucement s'il ya parfois on me dit que
j'ai triché 4 6 7 8 9 10 et celle là
c'est la 11e fois ci c'est le 5 de
carreaux j'aurais vraiment beaucoup de
chance
laterrière beaucoup de chars se serait
improbable ah bon effectivement c'est un
tour que je réussis en moyenne une fois
sur 52 parce qu'elle même pas de suite
autour c'est vrai à la hausse
le tour c'est une blague ou je dis tout
simplement
voilà ce tour là je ne réussis une fois
sur 52 mais quand il le réussit il ya un
effet de mal et alors la conscience que
j'ai eu c'est vrai que je n'ai vu un
montage te passer lentement et je
trouvais que réagissait pas vite au
moment où tu avais retourner la carte
team wasquehal élire la de choquer la
surprise sur ton visage et chelsea c'est
pas possible c'est en fait je me suis
dit je vais lui faire une blague je vais
faire semblant que c'est faire un tour
et au moment où j'ai vu un kart
bon j'ai choqué dans ma tête mes amis
mais je suis dire aux enchaînements qui
a way of autumn accord que c'est vrai et
je suis tout motif une désolé mais nadal
a menti il n'a pas de toit basse y avait
un tour il est déjà exceptionnel c'était
le tour qu'on pouvait pas expliquer j'ai
une chance sur 50 de halage la russie
alors si ce qui est très longue
c'est que la veille je les fais quand
même et ça a marché aussi avec mon club
et de laon la tournée on l'a tourné pour
le 24 mai à noël je vais refaire mon
neveu je leur taper à noël devant toute
la famille j'ai retrouvé dans la carte
s'arrêter de si bons que ça arrive une
deuxième fois mais merci on peut tromper
mille fois mille personnes dans vingt
mille peut on peut tromper mille bonnes
non feu
youtube ouais tu vois ce que ça fait bah
ouais je vous ai rangé la tous les
abonnés de fabien qui en ont marre de
tous ces tours au moins il a vu tu sors
c'est une vengeance parce que tu m'as
laissé le sentiment d'émerveillement
pendant un mois et demi j'étais vraiment
j'y tiens ouais ça se voyait je
tremblais à moitié bien que malte et au
niger croyait à 90% s'est agi à cet
événement il a peut-être un truc de fou
ouais bon top 10 si vous connaissez pas
c'est assez étonnant alors foncez voir
sa chaîne pour regarder quelques vidéos
et assez naturellement vous allez avoir
envie de vous abonner
c'est comme ça c'est la vie de top 10
comme quoi mon intuition de départ était
la bonne ma théorie était la bonne je
l'avais dit dans les commentaires et sur
les formes de magic personnes me croyais
que j'étais sûr que c'était ça enfin sur
mon comme d'habitude vous pouvez vous
abonner si c'est déjà fait n'oubliez pas
de cliquer sur la petite loge qui en bas
c'est important et n'hésitez pas à me
dire qu'elle était à vous votre théorie
si vous aviez trouvé ou pas dans les
commentaires
à très bientôt au début de semaine
prochaine je crois que je vais préparer
du lourd ciao
[Musique]
et